okay joining me as promised I'm not
taking my glasses off because they
cannot wait to to do this he's a great
friend of mine and zooming in from the
great outdoors here in beautiful lovely
Southern California sheltered in place
himself one of the stars of Goldbergs
and the Goldbergs and of course Curb
Your Enthusiasm my buddy Jeff Garlin how
are you Jeff I gotta tell you I'm doing
fine um couple of thoughts number one
this is the only show I'm doing I have
said no to other I'm not I don't want to
name names but just know other famous
sports talk shows other shows I mean
everything and then also all those damn
things where you're performing from your
living room Oh screw that I mean if you
want to watch me I'm on Netflix I'm on
HBO I might ABC I'm good I don't need
anyone to watch me during a pant a
pandemic and the other thing I want to
say is how blessed are we to live in
Southern California because the idea
that people are putting up with this
[ __ ] in in the cold places and for us
it's kind of cool right now it's not
even that warm but Wow to be able to sit
outside and read a book what have you
delightful so are you love
I'm good being alone okay so you are you
are flat out quarantined like you are
you know with my little dog sage sage is
the dog from the Goldbergs are you like
oh yeah about six months ago I said into
the dogs trainer on the show I said I'm
thinking about getting a dog she goes
would you like sage apparently and sage
plays lucky just answer to lucky but hey
sage sage sage sage come here come here
yeah Xochitl come next to me she's so
adorable and what a great mate I mean
holy [ __ ] for for what does it like 12
days I've been in my
best friend Tamir come up here come here
I want to show her the meat can I do the
rack around thing or whatever oh yeah
oh my god there's their sage yeah hi
baby
yeah it's lucky he she's just the people
here my kids out can you hear my kids
yeah kid but you're you're blessed I
know I know but I put on the flip side
my boys are with Marla boys when I say
boys for those who are watching my sons
are 20 now 19 and 24 one just turned 24
ones about to turn 20 but I miss them
terribly and I would have loved if one
of them was real with me we sheltered in
place with you so what are you what what
is what is a day consists for you Jeff
um I'm I'm watching a lot of netflix and
amazon prime Hulu all these different
things I am a hang and play with my dog
I play guitar I'm writing I'm going I'm
working a bunch of different TV shows
and movies so I'm doing a lot of writing
um
napping how are you isn't it your mom
don't do you just threw me a softball
and you know it I am the best
you know my Marla used to say that the
only reality show that I would ever go
on is napping with the stars because I
would destroy I would destroy my little
bench here I could fall asleep there in
two minutes
two minutes and I'm gonna do stars and
that's it you might be a judge on
napping with the stars though right I
mean you wouldn't just be a contestant I
think you'd be a by the way you know you
say that and I never took it that far
and hell yes hell yes
just sitting can you imagine all right
picture three stars judging as someone
climbs up and what they can do is they
can sleep on anything that's the skill a
bed of nails
a real bed a stool and see where they
fall asleep and then we critique them
while there
can I tell you something if that's not
hilarious I don't know what is you can
basically say you know what I lied down
and I appreciate the way that you got in
Tom really but your REM your REM state
can use a little bit of work no you're
being far too gracious I would be hard I
know that was an embarrassment
you call that a nap that's not a nap
that's an embarrassment
I would not be gentle with the bad
Nappers but I'd be abusive
you're a good damper I'm in bad of
course I mean you can you can recognize
greatness can you see it this thing
doesn't move what are you talking I'm
gonna make sure that tell me what I'm
looking at you you're looking at me
right now done okay we're good to use it
a curb I guess moment you are looking
more like Harvey Weinstein right now
just like in the others I've got the
I've got the gruff yeah yeah yeah more
like but not like I looked at they like
a rapist I am NOT a stop it people come
up to me hey Harvey shut up shut up no
but by the way yes but I'm in the
process cuz I'm done unfortunately done
with the Goldbergs I'm in the process
now of growing a beard okay that's what
you're doing that's video yeah watch it
even gets to be about yours I'll be fine
with the army king yeah this is this is
this is like day eight you know this is
what I got going on right now
oh hi of day ten I'm actually further
along than you I can't tell I don't look
can I be honest with you don't look at
my face a lot I don't go in the mirror
and go what's going on up there I don't
I shave in the shower when I would okay
I'm the only time I look in the mirror
is when I brush my teeth don't know why
but that's what I do right sure how'd
you meet the season 4 of curve was just
amazing Jeff I mean it was just as laugh
out loud as it has ever been
what was your favorite dumb do you
remember me I mean I told you a long
time ago before you saw them because
you're part of the curve viewing team or
whatever it's called
I told you it's my favorite season you
did today like what we've seen it what
what what made it you voted to me
everyone has gone into a store or a
coffee place or whatever and been
treated poorly and thought to myself how
the [ __ ] can I get you
it takes an insane person to walk
outside see if a place for rent and
build a spite story I gotta tell you I
don't remember laughing as hard as I did
at Sean Penn in the bird store I mean
that really that was a punch in the face
laughs that killed me
that was brilliant and that was that was
in the season finale my favorite part
about Larry's Speights tour was no
defecating there were no places Oh
defecating it's for you oh you know what
we would film all that stuff I would
just be bursting out laughing you know
it's ironic that we did the poop episode
because Larry doesn't really like that
kind of humor I know the licorice
episode and it was so I guess if he's
gonna do it it's gonna be because that
to me was the funniest episode when
Richard you hear a stomach one is each
stage as he's doing I was crying as he
was doing a performance of Marty on
stage live Marty no no wasn't Marty it
was the one with the mentally challenged
guy oh I forgot that forget what that
the name of it it's not Marty Marty is
not Marty's not mentally challenged when
we were all mentally generous it's right
right and it was so funny and another
funny hilarious episode was you know you
one of my favorite scenes was I hope
this is right but you taking Susie to
the airport yeah I did to drop her off
because no on a golf trip by the way
Vince bottom is phenomenal this year and
the best the best so talented to go on a
Pebble Beach Golf
rip and she just sensed your euphoria
and my dough I know by saying screw it I
am NOT going I had a lot of fun shooting
that scene well I assume you that was
your choice of song to sing correct oh
yes yes they told me any song I wanted
it was Larry Larry and Jeff Jeff
Schaffer for those you know watching as
a director and a producer
Larry's a producer I'm a producer and
John Heyman Carol Leifer I want to name
all the people that do that come up with
the creative stuff anyhow Larry and
Shemp said to me I go you guys got a
song in mind cuz when I read it there
was no Sun so long before and they said
no whatever you want as soon as I said
Hanukkah on Hanukkah they both started
laughing right you know we had Nick
Kroll in studio a couple weeks ago
before oh yeah for the the ugly section
oh my god okay so dig this we're filming
the guy having the heart attack in the
ugly section right Larry and I see
they're you know as in the show across
the restaurant in the ugly section and
we watched his real time we're sitting
there and the first time we shut it
we're not on camera there's no it's just
on the angle of Nick coming out and
going who help me help me someone's had
a heart attack in the good-looking
section or ugly section because we were
in the good-looking section well anyhow
hey Larry David Larry David and I looked
at each other the first take when he did
it it took us ten minutes to stop
laughing yeah because it was just the
Lea you know you read it Larry writes it
you read it and you seeing it as a whole
other what happened am I going now what
happened here you're okay um I can my
thumb's holding the bottom um you get
off mice there we go oh yeah so you
now you read it and you laugh cuz it's
funny right but seeing it especially for
the first time especially something that
absurd destroyed he and I we were crying
we were laughing so hard but I have to
say on that show okay there is so much
joy in doing the work on that show being
you know improvising and being on camera
and filming it that we I'm not gonna say
literally but most of our day is spent
laughing really hard I'll never have
this much joy doing a show but it comes
through Jeff and we sit there as fans
and watch it and just you know j.b
smoove every word out of his mouth
well don't and by the way also what's
also great for all of us is everybody
who works on the show all the actors
improvisers and producers are champs so
it's like you're spending time with
quality people and laughing all day it's
like how did what this is just amazing
you know cuz even when I go on to do
other things like I've done an
improvised movie with Bob Odenkirk and a
bunch of people called dealing with
idiots that was about Little League
baseball that was so joyful so fun
laughed all the time but I rewrote it so
it's not gonna be as funny if Larry
David wrote it no are you and I'm not
I'm not being mean to myself I'm
comparing myself to a genius I have
moments of genius comedic Lee but I am
NOT an out now genius
I am honored to work with one so no
matter what I think whatever I do could
be great it could be don't know whatever
my next thing is but unless Larry
David's running it it will not be
anything as good as curb well I'm
hearing one of the next things you'll be
doing is another season of curb Jeff is
that true well yeah yeah yeah that's
that's yeah well yeah because they're
and they started did they tell you there
might be some facetiming there might be
some zoom oh that's good
because they're bored well but I have a
strong feeling we'll do another season
strong feeling it has to happen I mean
it is well yeah I think that the
response you know I was just talking to
Larry the other day and the response
from people has so energized us not that
we didn't have passion or energy for the
show but we're so appreciative of
people's reaction to this season which I
can unequivocally say in 10 seasons our
strongest reaction season 10 which is
really crazy our show's crazy to begin
with but they're the what the season
that people love the most being season
10 Wow and so I know we're really
excited about doing another season if it
works out faster I say if it works out
because here's the thing people have to
understand Larry what Larry Jeff what
Larry we'll bounce ideas Larry will go
right and and by the way I've said this
on your show before I have never in the
history of our show pitched an idea to
Larry David
not one all right yet people come up to
me on the street and they give me their
ideas and I'm like no I don't think I'm
worthy of doing it how are you and I
tell them it's not gonna be funny go
ahead and then every one of them I react
like they just gave me a bad nap and
I'll say to them see it stinks I'll say
that to people don't give it to me but
anyhow it's uh yeah I'm just joyous
about the opportunity of doing another
season it would be great it would be
great all right so let's get just a
little bit of sports what do you think
by the way I'm dying to talk anything
sports I'm always mother for you
anything and mostly I'm like I don't
want to talk about curb but let's go
daddy-o
okay Nick Foles is a bear would you
think of that move good
why that's a I think like Jimmy Graham
good move uh Nick falls very good
what he is is a competent quarterback so
either help push true--but ski to raise
his game and by the way my gut you want
my prediction on true--but ski he
doesn't run the gamut with the Bears
he's done with the Bears after you know
his contract runs out he goes to
somebody else someone gets injured he
gets in he does great because he's the
guy you know different type things for
rookie quarterbacks he's the guy who
needed to and needs to sit behind a guy
like Nick Foles
for a season or two now what's
unfortunate right now is the timing
because we have the Bears have this
killer defense I mean a great defense
top top five in the NFL and you add yeah
but also you know the offensive line
didn't do the job last year and then
people want to know why a lot of I blame
blame trubotsky don't get me wrong and
I'm an American so I'm blaming I hate
him but offensive line play not so great
play calling not so great
I thought the receiver is fantastic so
running game could have been better but
I believed the running game by the way
on the offensive line there's only one
running there's like one kind of running
back that can work with the shitty
offensive line and that is Jim Brown
Walter Payton like they have to be the
extreme amazing top of the world
otherwise just Payton didn't always have
a good offensive line
he didn't um he had a fun offensive line
and they gelled but for years he did not
have a good of it's one but he's Walter
Payton all the Bears don't have anyone
remotely close to Walter Payton you know
I thought that uh not keeping Jordan
Howard was a big mistake
you know what I'm by the way you know
he's gonna benefit now is the Dolphins
Jordan Howard Jordan hours I think only
27 I mean he couldn't you know stay
healthy all last season for the Eagles
but when he was healthy I mean people he
was when he was just fed the ball over
and over boom boom boom
I don't know what went down in him with
him in the coach or him in the GM
something had to have gone down to get
rid of a player like that but I think
you're right that this is this is as I
said this on the show when the the trade
happened was one of the last days that
we were in studio was that it it lifted
the kimono on on their thoughts that
true Biscay may not be the guy and no
they can't they can't come out and say
it until they cut him and here's you
know Brian pace is hoping for and I'm
gonna go in and I'm gonna do conjecture
I'm not big on conjecture he is hoping
that either his boy Mitch or probably uh
what we call it will be and it falls
will be a good quarterback have a really
great season make the playoffs
I mean dream is a Super Bowl but make
the playoffs do decent in the playoffs
maybe lose the championship game and
then the next year when he releases
Stravinsky it'll be like well we're in a
good position we're moving forward
do you know I mean instead of what might
happen is they stink again this year
they barely eked out eight and eight
last year so they'll but if they barely
do that again pace has lost its job no
matter how much the Bears are not the
kind of organization that fire is easy
I know it's again it's it's um it's um
you know I you know I wish the Bears
coach was and the best coach they've had
the past 25 years
lovie smith yeah lovie smith loved by
his players got the team to a Super Bowl
are you kidding me that's hard work no
everyone loved lovey
Chicago loved lovey since then not so
fun I mean two years ago that's the
whole thing is that when true Biscay was
winging it around and they got the
double doink to knock him out of the
playoffs which by the way was the last
time Nick Foles wanna won a game as a
quarterback you know it
like it was gonna you know go in this
direction but they don't have the same
weaponry that the Chiefs have and that's
the obviously the office right but so
then no one's saying they're gonna win a
Super Bowl anytime soon but I like I'm
pretty pleased with the receiver core
they can do a little they can improve
everywhere but mostly mostly now that
we've got a actual quarterback not a
star but boy oh boy
this guy is he's a good quarterback a
very good quarterback not great but as
moments of greatness maybe he's the
equivalent of me he's a good man and you
miss it you can a prett but the point
thing is true--but ski a dotted shot
couldn't do it I know hey did you hear
the ESPN documentary on Jordan might be
moved up because they're trying to you
know obviously put programming on here
well I heard a rumor like you know they
said look it's not finished and me doing
what I do I know when you're not ready
for something to be seen by group but I
heard that some people have already seen
it and said it's great I mean like some
people at ESPN so maybe they're just
rushing right now to finish it and
they'll get it up it'll be so exciting
your favorite Jordan moment give it to
me which one which which out of all of
the moments was your favorite Michael
Joe I mean I would say the shot I mean
for me I've got two of them what is
personal one is completely on the court
on the court was the shot with the flu
against the Cavs okay that was like are
you [ __ ] kidding me because I'll tell
you why and it's ironic I'm talking
about
coronavirus but the coronavirus doesn't
feel like the flu I've gotten the flu
shot for over 25 years not gotten the
flu in over 25 years I am so I hate
nausea not that anyone's like oh I can't
wait to get nauseous again but I it's
the only thing that brings about dread
depression like it when I get nauseous
as a human being I
completely collapse I made a joke at my
head that the only two things I actually
hate are nausea and Nazis and I said the
worst thing in the world would be be
captured by Nazis while having the flu
so I don't like
so the idea game the flu you're mixing
the bureau to show the flu game was
against the Jazz and the finals but I
think you were about to say the shot
over ello for the cast was that wait
hold on what isn't the flu game against
Cleveland
yeah but the Cleveland shot was the one
over e lo where he'd been finally yeah
yeah but I thought he had the flu no
that's just I think he was he was very
healthy that day but maybe I'm wrong I
don't know you're the bear you're the
big bulls trying to do no I'm not the
Bulls fan on the Clippers fan oh that's
right do not insult me by saying I'm a
Michael Jordan fan you know Michael
Jordan Bulls fan but I am all-in I'm the
clear bomb or BFF all of a sudden
Palmer's BFF and I have season tickets I
bought its best purchase ever because I
bought them before we signed the two
guys and I say we because I'm gonna be
part of it I'm gonna ask you about him
$100 be part of the ownership group just
have my picture as part of it I am you
think I'm kidding
I won't do 100 I'll do what do you think
100 hours is equal to a penny probably
bring the world of Steve Ballmer yeah
but I'm gonna ask him how much can you
say a junior junior owner and what do
you call the junior owner in the program
what can I do here we go and then we'll
bring a full circle napping owner a
napping owner napping on a nap through
all the napping Basketball Association
that's the guppy oh by the way that's
another thing how could you make it shot
well what were you asking me when I went
on the nausea engine knows a game to
join yeah I don't know personal one
which the personal one personal one
I was with Allan Havey I in Chicago
Bulls are playing the it's the
championship series the Knicks which
that so they used to always you know is
either the Pistons are the necks
it seemed
like that's who we had to get through
and the Knicks it was just so
interesting so maybe we got an
all-access pass so I'm in the bowels yes
literally the bowels of of old Chicago
Stadium and the Bulls come out and
they're kind of they're kind of loose
they're not like tight but Jordan walks
out and damn if they all don't get
really loose immediately it's almost
like all right he's playing and they're
all like talking and slapping hands and
so [ __ ] loose all right I go around
the corner and we watch the Knicks they
came out didn't say a word didn't touch
each other nothing I the game was
already over done done finished
and I'm being on I was on the Knicks
side of that and we just always knew
Giorgio was Allan Havey our neighbors
big nips guy oh my god Wharton was gonna
cut out our hearts and show it to us
pumping by the way I like them that
where'd you say you met doing in person
oh I was saying that that Jordan we
always knew that he would cut out our
hearts and show it to his pumping and
then the one time when Jordan loved the
White Sox Charles Smith could kept
missing one layup after another it's
like still in slow motion
well that memory is hilarious that
memory is hilarious
no Michael Jordan bruce lee muhammad ali
few guys you can mention in that breath
you know it yeah so um no that was that
was amazing and the privilege of seeing
Jordan play in person on the balls you
know but I took it for granted I was
young I'm sure all right Jeff you're a
good man to step outside in your
backyard I miss Wade away although I
know you want to wrap this up and I
believe me I regret doing this ooh
what I wanted to talk about was
yesterday was opening day or are you
wearing this today
from Friday okay well yesterday if I'm
not mistaken was opening day without a
finger opening day I that to me is
hurting so much not being able there's a
look for me baseball is the opposite of
nausea nausea depresses me throws me out
of whack
baseball steers me straight I agree they
just care of me
it's like someone pending my end so I'm
alone and no one's putting my head Rick
no David Ross to take your head David
Ross by the way you know damn well if
David Ross is sitting right here and I
said David let's show rich pet my head
he would fed my head and tell me
everything's gonna be okay
and you know what else so would you man
that's the kind of man you gotta be to
leave the Chicago Cubs where that would
pet my head certainly since you have
probably haven't got a haircut in quite
some time it looks like I'm not by the
way did you watch Jojo Medan take his
bike ride no I didn't Oh
find it find it it's him with the zoom
on his head telling you the story of his
life in 1979 he actually because
something reminded him of that but
what's amazing about it is just him
being so Joe Maddon said he's running
around this trailer park in Arizona
waving at people and just almost gets
runs over it stays completely calm those
on the local baseball field and talks
about how beautiful is anyone watching
look up Joe man got his bike ride it was
so inspiring by the way doesn't say the
most interesting stuff it's the way he
says it that makes it delightful all
right that's the one thing is he talked
about it difficult painful restaurant
and things you know that's interesting
you painted a restaurant conversation
over it keeps going and going but the
way he does it is so beautiful ah is
mere fact I I'm gonna try and get a get
my hand on the original copy of it okay
I'll tell we'll look for it I'll look
for it I love you Jeff Garlin thanks for
doing this I love you too Rich Eisen
and good luck everybody stay safe and
I'm yeah just stay safe all right
later but take it easy bye